dépannage de fumée et une situation
incertaine ici dans les environs de
sieve hérodonietsk les combats font rage
depuis plusieurs heures les tirs
d'artillerie pleuvent comme sur la
maison de cet habitant une civile prise
entre deux feux après le départ des
forces ukrainiennes stationnées dans sa
rue
ce n'est pas clair nous ne savons même
pas d'où ça vient nous attendions à ce
que les tirs arrivent de là en pensant
que l'armée ukrainienne nous saurait
mais là c'est arrivé par là-bas il a des
tirs d'obus qui viennent de tous les
côtés
après quatre semaines d'invasion
l'état-major russe avait annoncé se
concentrer sur l'est de l'Ukraine et
particulièrement le Dombas nombre de
soldats russes se sont retirés des
environs de Kiev et se redéploie
maintenant massivement dans cette région
ici force séparatiste et armée
ukrainienne se battent depuis 8 ans déjà
je mange nous pouvons dire que les
forces militaires russes sont commencées
la bataille du Dombas pour laquelle il
se prépare depuis longtemps
une grande partie de l'armée russe se
concentre sur cette offensive
peu importe le nombre de soldats russes
sur place nous nous battrons nous nous
défendrons notre groupement
et nous ferons tout ce que nous devons
faire pour garder ce qui appartient à
l'Ukraine et ce qui n'en fait pas partie
nous n'en avons simplement pas besoin
vers une stratégique au sud du Dombas la
ville de Mario Paul est assiégée par les
russes depuis un mois et demi ce
dimanche ils ont lancé un ultimatum au
dernier défenseur de la ville leur
demandant de déposer les armes un par
les combattants Ukrainiens leur premier
ministre a annoncé que ses soldats se
battraient jusqu'au bout